I very often get asked what can you do
personally and I would wish there were
very very simple easy answers
unfortunately it turns out the most of
the things that we are talking about
when we talk about global problems
global warming as well as many of the
other problems in the world a much more
systemic we can't sit down and invent a
vaccine for malaria we can't distribute
mosquito nets to avoid malaria and
likewise it's very hard for us to make
really radical choices that will cut
back our carbon emissions dramatically
now this doesn't mean we shouldn't be
changing our light bulbs and we
shouldn't be driving a Prius if we can
but we should recognize that the
solution is not predominantly with
individuals it is with systems and
societies likewise I think businesses
need to focus on doing good yes but they
also need to ask that the fundamental
problem of tackling both sustainable
growth and to tackle all the other
problems in the world is this a systemic
issue not just one that any one
individual business can take on
business is often asked to do good in
their own to cut back on their carbon
emissions and follow up on other
corporate social responsibilities but
what we have to realize is that it is
systemic issues that drive what actually
works in societies where as business of
course can cut back in their carbon
emissions that's going to cost them
money and so at the end of the day this
is much more about having a society that
sets a price on carbon so that
businesses know what they're supposed to
do just like it's not up to businesses
to cure malaria to fix HIV or
malnutrition but businesses can help and
so we need to recognize that yes
businesses should be as cost effective
when it comes to energy they should
certainly pick some choices where they
say we're going to do good in the world
for instance on malaria or malnutrition
but we should also recognize that at the
end of the day this has to be a societal
decision and not one that just anyone
business can do
often the businesses that are most
successful are the ones that are first
movers and picking the easy politically
correct targets often targets that won't
actually do very much but get a lot of
PR so we should be honest if the
corporate social responsibility there's
really just about PR you should pick
easy targets you should pick targets
that have high visibility in today's
current discussion but if your goal is
to actually do good you should be asking
yourself well where do we get the most
return on social investments on the
money that we're going to be spending
and those are very often much less
visible much less interesting but
ultimately much more important issues
like a persistent malnutrition from
micronutrients something you don't ever
hear about but something that actually
affects about half the world's
population so take your pick do you want
to be popular in the press or do you
actually want to do good